[Music]
hey guys i'm george campbell co-host of
the ramsay show and i'm here to
introduce a limited series that we've
created called the best of the ramsay
show we've put together episodes
featuring some of the top clips from the
show you're going to hear how to take
control of your money some of the most
shocking calls calls about relationship
problems real estate investing dave
ramsey rants our takes on current events
and more and in this first episode we
walk through the seven baby steps to
winning with money unpack why credit
cards are not your friend explain the
debt snowball method do some myth
busting around building wealth and dive
into why you need an emergency fund so
sit back relax grab some popcorn maybe
some rice and beans and enjoy
so george 30 years ago when i started
teaching this stuff i was first teaching
people how to get out of debt
live on a budget
be generous
live on less than you make so you have a
plan you avoid debt you save money for
emergencies and later for investing
and all of those principles work but
people kept saying which one do i do
first
and so i started laying out well you
should do this first and that first you
should have an emergency fund before you
start your 401k
and uh
then i figured out it's easier to have
an emergency fund if you don't have any
payments
and so you need to get out of debt first
because of course i learned my lesson
the hard way going bankrupt and getting
out of debt and
learning how important it was to be
debt-free as a process as a part of
building wealth
so all of that started to formulate
after a few years of teaching
in various settings and what became
financial peace university it used to be
called life after debt
and it started becoming what we now call
the baby steps
the interesting thing is that now the
baby steps have gone into
the total money makeover book which has
sold almost 10 million copies
and they have become the proven plan
the shortest distance between where you
are now and wealth
where you are if you live like no one
else later you can live and give
like no one else what is the shortest
distance
and we need a path to run on because the
way you eat an elephant it's
overwhelming
do i do
my 401k with the match or my kid's
college
or do i have an emergency fund or do i
pay on this 18 credit card debt or
or or or or and nothing gets done you
get paralysis of the analysis you get
frozen absolutely and this step these
baby steps have worked for me they've
worked for millions and it's really
simple if you do it they work
and it all starts with baby step one
having this foundation saving one
thousand dollars for a starter emergency
fund this is just a small buffer between
you and life before we start tackling
the debt exactly and if you have a
thousand dollars already great just set
that aside that's your baby step one any
money you have that's not retirement
anything you can sell that is not
retirement you're going to liquidate it
if it's not retirement you've got some
stock over here that grandpa left you
you got a gold bar under your bed i
don't know what it is but you got any
money that's above a thousand dollars
maybe you've got ten thousand savings
account that's nine thousand dollars
you've got that you don't need past baby
step one we're gonna put it all on baby
step two and baby step two is the famous
one that's the debt snowball where you
list your debts smallest to largest you
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and you attack the little
one with a vengeance side note baby step
one should not take you more than 30
days
maximum you need to work extra sell some
stuff have a garage sale put the kids on
craigslist whatever you got to do here
let's get it done
and you know we're going to get busted
into this get a thousand bucks quick
baby step two you should be debt-free
but your house now you may have to sell
a stupid boat
uh you may have to take an extra job but
most people that have followed the total
money makeover baby steps in financial
peace university are debt-free inside of
two years yeah and that's with doing it
with some gazelle intensity like you
talk about in financial peace university
and once you pay off all that debt now
you've freed up all those payments right
you have that income about what it'd be
like to have no payments but a house
payment wow we're breathing easy
and then we can move on to baby step
three where we save three to six months
of expenses in a fully funded emergency
fund this is the final buffer where we
say we're never going back into debt
because we are the bank now yep
grandma's rainy day fund why it's gonna
rain dave you need to be positive i'm
positive it's gonna rain
you need to be ready when crap happens
there's a pandemic coming around every
corner there's something coming and if
you have twenty thousand dollars cash in
the bank three to six months of expenses
whatever it is
and you have no payments
you are the third pig
in the three little pigs the one that's
in the brick house when the big bad wolf
comes you're ready for life you're ready
to go now you're ready to build wealth
but that you just now have gotten up to
ground zero you've just now gotten up to
even
when you have that emergency fund and
you're debt-free now you're ready to
build wealth and baby step four you put
15
of your income
aside into good growth stock mutual
funds in retirement plans start where
there's a match beyond the match always
do roth
and if you've exhausted roth and match
and still are not to 15
then go on to a traditional 401k or ira
but do roths before traditional and do
match before roths
it's mathematically in your favor to do
that up to the 15 don't do 20
don't do 11
do 15
while you are doing baby steps four
you're also gonna be doing five and six
simultaneously absolutely so baby step
five is where we're saving for our
children's college fund and this is
gonna look different for everyone
there's no set number here because it
really depends on your situation did you
have the baby last week or is the baby
18
that makes a difference on how much you
need for college right what you got to
do for college just like is this an oh
crap moment or hey we're going to be
diligent and safe did we wait almost
until too late now they have to go to
college debt-free they cannot
participate in this epic student loan
system failure that is called america
right now it is horrible out there do
not let your kids go in debt you do not
have to go to debt go to community
college for free for two years go go to
in-state school work six jobs get
scholarships our student loan problem is
a parenting problem mom and dad let kids
sign up for crap they couldn't afford
bad mama bad daddy
they got to have the conversations
that's where it starts and there's a
reason you say baby step four invest for
yourself before the kids because there's
a hundred percent chance you're going to
retire there's a 50 50 chance or less
these days that your kid's going to go
to college and graduate yeah yeah this
is this less than 50 chance they're
going to graduate so
uh that that this is important so while
you're doing 15 you do whatever you need
to do for your kids college whatever you
decide to do for your kids college
beyond that if you can find any money
you do that on baby step six and that's
pay off your house
start chunking on the house now when
you're in one through three you are so
intense your friends are freaking out
your grandmother thinks you need
counseling you are gazelle intense like
a gazelle running from a cheetah when
you're in four through seven you're not
intense anymore you are now intentional
you're just doing it on purpose but
you're no longer on beans and rice your
own beans and rice rice and beans
scorched earth on one through three two
you get those three things done
now
get that house paid off the average
person following this stuff is paying
off their home in about seven or eight
years
now
that tells us that the whole program is
taking about 10 years and the average
baby steps millionaire the average
everyday millionaire that we've studied
we're finding them become a millionaire
from the time they start with intensity
followed by intentionality become a
millionaire in about 10 and a half years
yeah 11.2 years 10.6 years are the two
numbers we keep running into
so this is completely possible
today's question comes from diane in
arizona my husband and i are in baby
step two and are working hard to pay off
our debt the one issue we struggle with
is not using credit cards we use them to
pay our utilities groceries and other
monthly bills but we never carry a
balance
by doing this we're able to travel for
vacations for free using our points
what's wrong with doing this if we're
not going into more debt
the age-old question dave
the age-old question we've been
exploring this topic on the fine print
because it's one of the biggest
objections
we get uh here at ramsey are people
going well dave i pay off my card every
month i get some free stuff what's the
harm
right so we should clue in
bank of america and chase
what portion of their marketing is
working the best
and it is this crap the vacations the
points this is the one this is the one
that's got people believing in stupidity
still
after all this time yep and here's what
happens and you can listen to the the
true cost of credit card rewards this is
the second fine print episode that we
released and we dug into this with an
ex-capital one insider okay what did
they say uh she said they run 10 000
experiments a year on people to figure
out what's going to get them to spend
more to use the points and one of the
biggest ways they do it is through the
points because you know how the points
work they don't say it's 500 they say
you're going to get 128 000 points that
you can use to redeem flights that cost
74 000 and the points change every day
and there's blackout dates and there's
restrictions
and on top of that uh the whole two
percent cash back that one is one of my
favorites because you know what two
percent of a thousand dollars is
twenty dollar 20 bucks to spend a
thousand and uh that's not a great deal
so let me let me get this straight if
you spend ten thousand dollars
you get 200 bucks
ding ding ding that'll make you rich
yeah spend ten thousand get two hundred
that's a formula for wealth building
right there
we did an analogy did you people go to
grade school
listen diane here's the thing we did
this analogy in the in the podcast about
chuck e cheese cause this is what it
reminded me of dave you go to chuck e
cheese oh my god gives you a ten dollar
bill and you get these cool claw on toy
story yes
so you get your coins and you're so
excited to spend those coins that you
spent ten dollars on and you go and you
get all the tickets and you get 400
tickets and you go to the table at the
end of the day and you go wow i can get
any prize and they go nope you get
sticky hands and a pack of gum
and you go wow i spent ten dollars for
sticky hands and a pack of gum that cost
a quarter
yeah and i got screwed yeah i think so
uh here's the thing i don't have big
buildings dave uh the credit card
companies do they're sponsoring every
stadium in america and they're doing it
with billions of dollars that they're
making off of the backs of these people
who are overspending you yes yeah so
here's the thing
um
to start with
you're not going on vacation for free
that is an absolute asinine stupid
statement it is not true
you might have got your airline ticket
for free but everything else on the
vacation was not free so you're spending
money and you're going on vacation when
you should have been working because
you're in debt
you're not supposed to be going on
vacation when you're in debt
we follow everything you say no you
don't you don't go on vacation when
you're in debt and you don't go out to
eat when you're in debt you you work and
you work and you work and you clean your
dadgum debt up
and that is that that's the ramsey plan
now you can say you can you could go do
your plan if you want but don't say
you're doing my plan when you're going
on vacation because it's just not true
and here's the thing
the arrogance
that is required the intellectual
arrogance that is required for you to
think
that you are taking on
billion dollar companies who have
algorithms that know what bottled water
you drink
and you are somehow beating them and
you're you're you're fleecing them
you're getting an airline ticket and it
doesn't cost you anything you really are
pretty arrogant
to think that you're actually winning at
this game
i mean honestly
do you understand that when when
citibank when you call them
your zip code is pulled off your nsx
code and the person answering the call
if it's a friendly call is a person of
the same accent as you
if you call from the south you'll get a
syrupy southern bell accent
and if you call from the wicked
northeast you'll get a wicked
northeastern accent
you're gonna these people screw with you
on levels you have no idea and you think
you're beating them
yeah absolutely incredible so here's the
thing we did study we did a study of
millionaires we studied 10 000 of them
10 167
not a single one told us
we became millionaires with our free
vacation points because we ran all our
utilities our groceries and everything
else through a credit card and then we
went on vacation for free and it didn't
cost us anything and that's how we built
our wealth not one said that isn't that
odd
diane
so here's the thing
people that ask this question are people
that think they're beating the system
let me tell you how you beat the system
you don't play
don't play in the system you know what
it's like it's like being a mouse in the
maze and you get to the cheese and you
think i won i got the cheese and you
zoom out and you go no i'm just a part
of a giant social experiment that exists
to take my money
that's what it is
so you can play that game and that's
fine you can get your vacations but i'm
not in the in the business of trying to
gain points i'm trying to gain wealth i
want to complete the baby steps i want
to pay off my house i want to give
outrageously and that doesn't happen by
paying off my card every month and
reaping the benefits of two percent cash
back you know the chuck e cheese thing's
funny as crap oh it's great the team did
a great job with the edits we got the
coin sound
you got to go let's come out of there
skee ball or whatever they're just
coming out there like crazy you've got
this long line of tickets and your
little kid they think they're getting
the big prize and you get you never get
the big price nothing it's you got you
spent 10 to 20 bucks to get a prize that
cost less than 50 cents and the same
thing's happening when you go to book
these flights and you go well we can go
to boise
yeah i don't think uh martinique was on
the list was it no
you're not going the bahamas first class
i'm sorry so belize and bermuda are not
on the list no no
so san diego's nonetheless nashville's
not on the list no it's blackout
blackout dates blackout mean they don't
go
oh no they just won't take you
that's what it means i i think you can
do a lot better by using a debit card
and using cash and saving up for your
own dang vacations yeah you know where i
go on vacation anywhere you want there
you go
that's how that works and you know when
i use those credit cards that always
works so that's how it happens i haven't
had a credit card and my gosh it's
george
it's coming up on 30 years
wow we should have a party we should
we can't use points to pay for the party
though in police and police
i'm in how about cabo let's go to cabo
i'm in we're heading there man i'm
telling you ryan is with us brian's in
pittsburgh how are you brian
dave i'm good thanks for taking a minute
to talk with me my pleasure sir how can
we help
so i want to tell you about six weeks
ago i ran into a friend of mine that
retired and he was telling me how great
it was and asked me how much longer do
you have i said 12 years and
he started telling me get ready debt
free that's the only way to go
i hear him don't pay a lot of attention
to it my son
tells me a week after that hey i'm
listening to this ramsay show
never heard of it before i said what is
he new howard stern i don't know never
heard that yes he is
howard's got much better hair than i've
got
yeah
uh
so he tells me this a couple more times
i'm on a trip for work i got a lot of
windshield time i turn it on
i listen to six podcasts back to back to
back and i'm going to tell you i'm
hooked i get it i'm i am bought in wow
so i heard you say hey you got to know
everything that's going out everything
is coming in and what's your debt so i
did that i spent about 30 hours on that
last week
and let me tell you it's uh scary it's
emotional it was tough yeah and
so i've got
some debt and my question for you is
i have about 12 000 and change that we
have invested in the stock market single
stocks
and is it smarter to leave that there as
a savings i know there's a risk there
and or is it better to pull every penny
out of that
and put it towards the debt that we have
and that would that might would take
care of uh
i don't know 20 25 of it
but my goal i mean i want to be
debt-free i got 12 more years to retire
and i want to be debt-free when we get
there and i wanted to do it i met my
wife bought in on it now okay so you got
about fifty thousand dollars worth of
debt and twelve thousand dollars in
stock
66 247 to be exact all right good deal
what's your household income
uh about 180 190 annually okay all right
so
you've been listening and you know some
of the lingo now and some of the process
and the baby steps and all of that right
and so baby step two is where you are
paying off all debt except the house
using the debt snowball listing your
debts smallest to largest paying minimum
payments on everything but the little
one attacked the little one we stop all
investing temporarily and we use all
money that we can get our hands on that
is not in a retirement account to throw
it baby step two
and that's a standard baby step two
answer which would lead us to cashing
out your stock and paying off a fourth
of your debt
okay
not saving your when you talk about
emergency funds let me leave that there
i mean we got no cash saving how much
cash do you have
uh i don't know 11 12 grand something
like that okay we always baby step one
is one thousand dollars saved anything
above that goes on baby step two until
baby step two is done and so i'm gonna
use that money as well down to one
thousand dollars which is going to scare
the p wadding out of you by the way
that scares the hell out of that i know
i know and that's it should but you're
not gonna live there for very long
because now we've paid off uh 23 000 of
your 66 000
uh if i did my math right just now
and you have enough income to clear the
rest of it very very quickly
and as soon as it's cleared then the
first order of business is baby step
three
and that's build your emergency fund
back up to a full three to six months of
expenses which it's not now it's kind of
it's kind of anemic right now it's weak
right the two together would make a
decent emergency fund if you didn't have
any debt but
that's what we teach and here's the
reason
uh it's not to induce fear but the fear
will also help be one of your motivators
that oh crap moment you just had that
thing where your stomach just kind of
jumped up in your throat just at the
mere suggestion of doing this and we
hadn't even done it but just the idea
you go
you know we all do that we all have a
physical reaction to that um that is
going to drive you to stick with the
plan now to suggest that you keep a 1
000 emergency fund for five years or
something would be ludicrous and i don't
suggest that but we're talking about
just a mere months here again what was
your household income
uh 180 190. okay so how fast do you pay
off fifty thousand dollars six months
forty or no i'm sorry uh forty thousand
dollars
like what i mean
less than six months right
well my goal was two years i wanted to
do it before i'm 50. so that's that
sucks that's way too much sucks you make
180 000 a year
i need 40 000 of 180.
this is six months how much does this is
five thousand i want five thousand
dollars a month on this dad
i want you to smack the crap out of it
all right and then you're so you're done
by christmas dude
chris by christmas you're starting to
rebuild this emergency fund from one
thousand dollars up and then as soon as
you've got that three to six months of
expenses then you restart your 401k oh
by the way you put money in the 401k
right now
i took your advice and i backed it down
to the uh
minimum that the company matches okay
that wasn't my advice my advice was stop
it
i'll stop it all together well i
misunderstood i thought you you were
saying get you know don't let free money
go to the company matches
no no no now when you're in the hole man
you're just getting started on all this
you're trying so what i'm what i'm doing
is i'm not making fun of you and i'm not
picking at you but i'm giving you the
the
the detail that you haven't gotten in
the last couple weeks of exposure yet
and so what i need to do is i'm going to
send you the the game plan with all the
nuanced detail the baby steps on
steroids it's the best-selling book
called the total money makeover and
we'll give it to you as a gift hold on
kelly's going to pick up i'm going to
mail you one and you read that thing and
your wife read that thing and you'll see
what i'm talking about 180 minus 40 you
can make it on
okay 90 minus 40. 90 in the next six
months minus 40 and you're done by
christmas you can make it on and i just
put 11
and 12 on the debt so i know i put 23
out of there so it's 43 left
and so yeah you're there
you're going to be there
and that's that's what i would do if i
woke up in your shoes
the uh the great news is you've you've
found a new thing here and you're fired
up about it but it's about to get real
that's right
so imagine you imagine this this is this
is the feeling you had brian when you
put you spent 30 hours and you put that
debt down and you got emotional
that's you on the plains of africa and
you're a a gazelle and you just stuck
your head up and you just saw that lying
in the grass
and now you gotta take off running man
and that's what the next six seven
months is gonna be it's gonna be a
all-out
gut-wrenching sprint because they're all
intensity that's right
because they're coming for you man
they're coming you gotta ride
i wanna mention this i don't want this
to fly by david i know this makes me
sound sappy
it takes a special level of courage for
a grown man making this kind of money
which means he's got some kind of he's
got some some ego some strength
his son came in and said dad i think you
should look at this and most dads in
this situation go shut up
and he listened he just listened the
approach on the call was humble it was a
humble call and i want everybody out
there if your son comes says hey can we
just talk dad take that talk take that
that breakfast take that conversation
man
um that took a lot of courage for a son
to do and i'm proud of him but i'm proud
of that dad for listening man that's
cool yeah it doesn't happen very often
cool brunch got up he's got a thing
going on he does man i like it
he's comfortable on his own skin yeah
strong but making good decisions so yeah
you're gonna you're gonna go do this
brian and and then you're gonna call us
back do your debt free scream we're
gonna hear a great story from you it's
gonna be awesome what i love about brian
is i guarantee he's a leader and as a
leader he approached this with the
appropriate skepticism and then he did
the math and then as a good leader he
went oh crap you know what i mean
that's a good leader man not that
everything's perfect not that i gotta
come up with some stupid excuse but i
can see the data and i can go whoops we
need to change course quick right yeah i
don't think i did that one right i love
it man i love it that's this is there's
a formula here for everybody listening
yeah that that you know involves life
change
you know bible says be not conformed to
this world yeah this world's broke yep
i mean normal is looking good and no
money yep normal is you're driving a car
with a big butt payment on it
normal is you got a student loan that's
been around so long you think it's a pet
normal is you know you've discovered
master
card yes and discovered bondage in
american distress this is normal normal
sucks
dave ramsey doesn't know what he's doing
i mean everybody uses debt that's
wealthy
no
you must live in your mother's basement
and write that financial blog
because the actual data of wealthy
people is is that by and large they
don't use debt to get there by and large
they do get their homes paid off
the vast majority of america's
millionaires 93 of them did not inherit
their money according to an airtight
piece of research that the ramsey
research team did
and out of those 93 of america's
millionaires we studied over 10 000 of
them the largest study ever done
the vast majority of them
paid off their homes early
and had money in their 401ks and in
their roth iras and mutual funds and
that's how they get their first one to
five million
now if you want a billion
instead of for the first five million
if you want to jump try to straight jump
straight to a billion well you might
borrow money out your eyeballs that's
possible
but i'm not here trying to create
billionaires i'm here trying to create
millionaires
because i want families to be able to
retire with dignity be able to change
their family tree and be able to live
well
i don't need you to go broke six times
in the process getting there we're not
trying to write a success manual on
going broke over and over again by
taking all this risk
i went broke once and i did all of i did
that apparently for all of you so you
don't have to
because you can learn from my stupidity
you don't have to follow it
so
this i this this idea that sophisticated
people all borrow money is absolute
statistical hogwash
it's simply not true
they do
not now do sometimes billionaires yes
sometimes they do does somebody worth 30
million dollars maybe but you got 30
cents
30 cents
and you're losing some of your sense all
the time
and so don't talk to me about how
sophisticated people borrow money you're
freaking broke
they do not
now that's what i used to think
because that's what my broke finance
professor taught me
if your finance professor is broke
that's like having a shop teacher with
missing fingers
you should think about where you're
getting your advice
so
uh be careful when someone says oh well
such and such like ramsay is not
sophisticated the stuff we teach is
unbelievably profound and sophisticated
it just doesn't line up with your get
rich quick little immature self and you
don't like it some of you oh well
you don't have to follow it
this is america you have the right to be
wrong
you're allowed to go do whatever you
want to do
so she's brilliant she's done a great
job they've handled their money
beautifully and they're well on their
way to substantial wealth
and we meet everyday millionaires baby
steps millionaires who follow these baby
steps by the tens of thousands every day
i meet
more
and is it because i didn't make up any
of this i didn't invent any of this
it used to be called common sense
it's just now marketable because it's so
freaking rare
it's like having a superpower
i've made millions and millions of
dollars selling common sense
because there's not any out there
and so it turns out it's like a rare
commodity it's like finding a big old
diamond out in the middle of your
backyard look at that oh my god that's a
genius live on less than you make
who would have thought of that
you know but that's really that's where
we live instead we've got oh i'm gonna
bitcoin my way in and i'm going to play
the lottery
and i'm going to borrow and do nothing
down real estate and buy 73 houses with
no money and think that ain't gonna bite
me in the butt later
of course it's gonna bite you in the
butt later it's gonna take you to your
knees it did me and it will you
please don't do that stuff
you're gonna bring pain to your family
and then you have to do it all over
again it's much easier just to do it
slower and do it right
it's also faster to do it slower and do
it right
it's easier to do a job right the first
time and wealth building is no different
so walk these baby steps
and in 10 to 12 years you'll probably be
a millionaire most of you
but to the extent you don't then you
have to wander off and find your own way
because you're going to reinvent common
sense
that's just silliness
and that is not an indicator that the
stuff that the ramsey personalities and
dave ramsey teach is simplistic or out
of touch or he's such a boomer
oh my god you're such a child
you're just such a baby child
listen little baby child
here's the deal
the boomers got this stuff figured out
that's how i lived this long got this
thinking much money jennifer is in
houston hi jennifer welcome to the
ramsey show
hi uh thank you so much for having me my
pleasure quick question uh we are on
baby step uh four six and seven um we
completed baby step three then my
husband and i have a difference of what
that looks like so would we save three
to six months worth closer to three or
six
and does that if we like say if i lose
my job today right i'm not gonna go get
my nails and hair done so like down to
the bare minimum
or what actual six month spending looks
like
uh probably between these two at your
stage
uh and you can pick the three or the
sixth month that's not the issue but
then is it absolute bare bones or does
it mean no uh
uh
known there no no hair no nails all that
kind of stuff so um
uh uh what's your household income
um about 160 yeah
and um
how old are your two cars
uh how old uh i just bought a car for
cash of 2014 lexus and he has a uh
14 exhibition okay you got two good cars
yeah you're not you're not dying on cars
so here's the thing that i discovered
and the reason i'm asking these things
when you're broke and you're just
getting started you remember those years
back in the day
everything's a freaking emergency
because you're broke
right
and you're driving junk cars
and you know you haven't done all the
maintenance on the house so even more
stuff's breaking
and so it's like you're in the fact that
you're broke is inviting more strain
on the emergency fund later on when
you've got more money and the air
conditioner is getting serviced
regularly on the house and as soon as
there's one little thing on the roof you
fix it immediately it doesn't leak and
create a bigger mess and it's and you're
driving decent cars so they're not
breaking down and you don't wait until
there's a flat tire you happen to notice
when they're going getting a little bear
and you go change them out early where
when you're broke you have to drive them
until they blow you know
and so what happens is you get more
margin in all these areas of your life
so the weird thing is is the more money
you get the less need of an emergency
fund you have
because there's fewer emergencies is
that logical
yeah absolutely and we have a two 15
year old and a four-year-old and then
the only other factor would be that um
i'm wondering if we should pile it up a
little more i hate my job i've been
looking at ken coleman's stuff um and my
performance has not been where it should
be just because i'm i'm just making
myself get up and go to work every day
um should we add a little more to it
yeah that's not an emergency
okay that's a transition
if you want to set some money to the
side for job transition you can do that
feel free okay feel free set your 10 or
15 20 grand over there for job
transition but let's not confuse that
with the emergency fund
the emergency fund's for emergencies
this is not an emergency this is a
problem we need to fix
right christmas is not an emergency it's
always in december it's predictable
it's predictable that two years from
today you're not gonna be working at
that place
god i hope not
and jennifer listen
can i can i you didn't even ask this can
i push on you for a second
please do
please
don't sacrifice your dignity and your
respectability in your work ethic
and say things like my job performance
is slipping just because i don't feel
like going anymore
if you're still employed they're still
taking their money show up and give a
thousand percent and then when you're
looking for jobs give a thousand percent
on your job transition
but you will it will keep you from
walking six inches lower right with your
head health you will walk with your head
held high your chin held up you will
clean out your desk when you get that
new job with a smile on your face yeah
don't
you're not a person that mails it in no
that's not who you are
yeah so but yeah go ahead and make the
transition and set some money aside for
that and if you want to um
what's happening is is that transition
is scaring you and that's what's making
you want to put the emergency fund on up
and so put 25 000 over there right quick
in the next few months to make this
transition that's not that's a
transition fund it's not an emergency
fund and then you then you won't be
worried about your emergency fund
anymore because your emergency fund
probably just fine i love that idea dave
so that's you would a transition a new
baby coming you need to get a new car
none of those are emergencies those are
just we need to have a sinking fund that
we create and save up for that yeah you
know what the problem is and it's not
her situation but it's just all of us in
america we were just taught to have a
savings account that's it that's exactly
right one and you know what a savings
account is it's a put and take account
you put money in there you take it out
put money in there take it out and buy
bass boat put money in there fix air
conditioner put money in there put
stitches in the kid's head put money in
there it's a put and take put and take
put and take and so it's all this stuff
is combined in this one general account
that that you always watch it and it
just never seems to do what it's
supposed to do because no one knows what
it's really supposed to do it's never
enough or look at all that money i got
right yeah and when you separate out
your savings and you say every savings
dollar has to have a job a mission an
assignment okay this is you this one's
job is transition
this one's job is christmas this one's
job is car replacement and this one's
job is emergencies and don't confuse
them i love that buying a bass boat is
not an emergency there is no situation
ever on planet earth in which you can
describe a bass boat purchase as an
emergency it's not on the list i i can
emotionally get there but intellectually
we're all laughing right now right and
so you know that that's i was forced to
buy a new car no you aren't they didn't
have a gun
you chose to buy a new car and so th
these are the things but that's the
reason is it and it helped me a ton
uh because my nature's not a i'm not
naturally a saver it helped me a ton to
say these things have a goal because i
am goal oriented and once i have
something with a goal then ding ding
ding ding i can do it i love i'm writing
that down every
savings dollar has a job too
different than your light bill or your
food or what
every every dollar you are saving has a
job as well what we figured out a few
years ago is
there's 73 000 things coming at you that
wants your money
and then when you get some money
because you went to work or because you
get a lump sum or because you sold your
rental property or whatever it is you
get some money
you go i don't know which of these 73
000 do i do
how do i do this and people become
overwhelmed and they do nothing and then
they end up doing something stupid with
the money instead of actually being
intentional and having a plan
so
20 some odd years ago almost 30 years
ago
coaching families
we determined
that you needed a very specific clear
path
and we developed that over many years in
actual practice it was not theoretical
meaning tens of thousands of families
that we walked with to develop
these highly tuned
baby steps
and baby step one
comes
before
baby step two
it's not an accident that two is after
one
and that three is after two and that
five is after four and that six is after
five and that four is before five these
are not accidents
this is a highly
developed
highly
uh processed
series of concepts that are have proven
to tens of millions of families in
america now to be the shortest distance
between where you are in wealth now you
can go make up your own freaking plan
but your plan got you where you are
and so you need to decide
you know you don't need to call rachel
and anthony
and christie and deloney and me
and coleman and ask us if baby step
three
should be after baby step two
it is that's why we called it three
and you don't need to change it
it you know it's a pretty and it doesn't
really change
there's it is the shortest method
to get there shut up and do it okay tell
me this do you feel like you've heard
more of this
happening in the last five years
the last hour
the last few years versus over the last
20 because i feel like more than ever
today the culture it's a it's it's a
little bit infested with
yeah but this is my snowflake i'm a
snowflake i'm unique
you're unique but the law of gravity
applies to all snowflakes i know but i'm
just saying it did do you see it
culturally like do you think that that
like do you
do you see this resistance or have you
always always it's always been it's a
natural because it's your unique i mean
people say yes
because what happens is the very
confusion of the 73 000 things you can
do with money yeah you have to bring it
back to the table continually yeah until
you actually believe that there is logic
and data
and decades
and tens of millions of lives
that have done it the right way
and gotten the positive result until you
submit yourself to the plan you know
it's like hiring a personal trainer and
he says well you probably need to eat
less yeah but i'm not going to do that i
just want to do the workout
you know well no you got to eat less fat
boy
you know that's what i'm i'm looking in
the mirror i got a keg he's got a
six-pack
why am i arguing with the six-pack boy
about nutrition when i'm fat
why am i arguing with him he told me
what to do he i hired him i paid him to
tell me what to do and then i've got a
better plan and then i look at my belly
and go well how's that a better plan you
know this is what ought to go through
people's head yeah
it's true it's true
or the trainer says do more lunges i'm
like i don't want to do this
i don't like leg days
i don't like leg day
i don't think i want to do that yeah i
think i'm just going to pick out i'm
going to do my version of your plan that
works because my version has got me
where i am it's the dumbest thing ever
well it's not the dumbest thing ever
it's because i know why
because it feels good in the moment to
do what you feel like is safe
to do and stepping outside of what you
feel like is safe and doing a plan that
makes you uncomfortable because you're
having to change
that's why you know oh yeah
it's comfort zone crap yeah it is
exactly what it is but you have to
decide
you know you have to decide did your
comfort zone get you to where you are
yes do you like where you are no then
get out of your dadgum comfort zone you
look great though i've lost 37 pounds
because i looked in the mirror and i
went fat boy you got to do something
that's shape talk i did
i did look at myself joined alone it
caused me to it caused me to lose weight
though i mean you just you know your
self-awareness is part of the process
right oh my gosh
this is the ramsey show hey if you
enjoyed this click here to watch the
next episode with some of the most
shocking calls from the show